everyone can at least hear me and see me
preferably but we can't see you you
can't right well let's just have a look
[Music]
um
should be an option down on the bottom
left to start video there we go we can
now
right okay that's probably not better
but there we go
so my name is John Murray I'm a
solicitor and I'm the inspector
appointed by the Secretary of State to
hold this inquiry into determine the
Appeals I will confirm details of
appearances shortly but I understand
officer Mr Telford
um a planning consultant appears for
parents and Mr light head of council
appears for the local planning Authority
yes sir and um just dealing with a few
procedural matters largely in relating
to the fact that it's a virtual event
um now as I said
um I think
um it appears at the moment that I can
only pin one one face to the screen but
I think it needs the host to enable
multi-pin
um if that could be done don't worry
um if it can't but um I think that's the
answer because
come on there might be a gallery view
um to type to yes I've got it on gallery
view but
um it just means that I've got lots of
small images rather than
um are on the actual speaker at the time
yes so
um
sorry there's also a switch to active
speaker can you see that on the screen
questions
uh no this was the trouble here these
things don't always look how you expect
them to look to everybody else
uh speaker
just just one procedure about to please
if I may I just need to advise or ask
Martin if he wouldn't mind streaming it
please well I think if you're still
there
you do you don't mean media no I don't
mean you sorry no there's another chap
in the Council on Martin garbage
thank you very much
okay that's it thank you
sorry I I was having problems yesterday
with connection and it looks like that's
going to continue today so I've just had
a message to say my internet connection
is unstable so that's that's uh that's a
good start yeah
um I asked whether um the proceedings
were being live streamed or recorded
it's being live streamed right does
anybody have a problem any any objection
to that
right okay
let me know if that changes at any point
now um if you could just make sure as as
you would in a a face-to-face event that
mobile phones have switched to silent
and unless unless you're speaking can
you also
um keep your microphone muted to avoid
uh background noise
um and except for The Advocates I know
there's a position slightly different to
council because you've got several
people there but apart from The
Advocates
um if you could also make sure your your
camera is Switched Off unless you're
actually speaking just to have a word of
distraction and obviously it goes
without saying but it's even more
important in Virtual events to avoid uh
try and avoid more than one person
speaking at a time if we can literally
like better them after all
um but if you need to ask or
um uh Interjet interject or ask
questions then please use the raise hand
function
um there should be a reactions icon yes
there's a reactions icon at the bottom
so if you click on that then you'll see
the raised hand function
and um then just lower your hand when
you're finished
um there is a screen sharing facility
but I'd rather avoid using that unless
it's absolutely necessary and if it's
necessary to share documents if they
could be emailed to each party including
the planning inspectorate using the team
E2 email address for the inspections
now bear in mind that all parties not
all parties may be familiar with digital
events it was it may look as if I'm not
but I have done quite some quite a few
um and you know the technology may not
be familiar to everybody so just ask for
your patience and understanding during
the event and if you lose connection
just an idea during the proceedings or
have any other concerns about
connectivity then please contact the
council if someone does lose connection
then I'll adjourn probably initially for
five minutes
uh and in that time just trying to log
it back in as you did at the start
or contact the council and the contact
information is on the journey
instructions including telephone number
if the problem persists then a longer
adjournment may be needed and if it
can't be resolved we may have to return
to another day
um digital events again speaking or
experience can be quite demanding and
tiring so I do intend to have regular
breaks anyway but if you're feeling
adjournment is necessary anytime for any
reason
they're just you know
um it's obviously important in the
insurance of interest to the openness
that before during and after the event
are not left alone as it were with any
particular party so when we do adjourn
just please allow me to leave the zoom
meeting before you do
I will leave completely so I can't see
or hear anything that's being said and
um I'll be join at the state time
and please make sure you're back by the
state of time during adjournments you
will be able to stay in the virtual
meeting if you want to the meeting room
um and you can speak to each other or
mute and turn off your cameras if you
need to have a private conversation
if we join in the middle of uh
cross-examination of a witness that
witness mustn't communicate with any
other member of their team during that
German and similarly Witnesses can't be
prompted by others whilst giving
evidence
preferably
um no one should be in the same room at
the same time but at least if I can see
what's going on in the room that's
that's not so bad
um if the opposing Advocate has any
concerned at any stage about the
possibility of a witness being prompted
just just raise them sometimes I'm
looking down writing rather than looking
at what's going on on the screen
I will miss itself come back to the
discussion about postponement
adjournment Etc
but I just want to First outline matters
relating to the substance of the inquiry
thank you so the inquiry is into two
appeals made by Mr Robert Hatfield
against two enforcement notices issued
by Northeast Derbyshire Council on the
1st of November 2021 in respect of land
at brindwood House milthorpe Lane
homesville Derbyshire and appeal a the
note is subject to appeal a
um in that note is the breach of
planning control has alleged is without
planning permission the material change
of use of a building to use as a single
dwelling house use class C3 in the
location shown filled purple on the plan
attached to the notice and that's there
after called the building and the
requirements of the notice are to Cease
the use of the building of the dwelling
house removed from the land all fixes
and fittings installed inside the
building to facilitate its use as a
single dining house and the period for
compliance with the requirements is four
months after the date on what's the
latest takes effect and that appears
proceeding on the ground set out in
section 174 subsection 2D of the 1990
act which is essentially that it's too
it was too late to take enforcement
action
the relevant period is four years prior
to the issue of the enforcement notice
so that takes us back to the 1st of
November 2017.
and then the notice the subject of
appeal B alleges firstly without
planning permission building operations
comprising the erection of an L-shaped
garage building in the approximate
position shown filled blue on the
attached plan and secondly without
Planning Commission building operations
comprising the erection of a building in
the approximate position shown filled to
Green on the attached plan
and those are thereafter referred to as
in authorized buildings and the
requirements of notice are a demolish
the unauthorized buildings including any
half-standing foul drainage connections
and or buried tanks and remove all
materials arising from their demolition
from the land
and then reseed the ground following
compliance with step a with a general
agricultural grass seed mix even
scheduled msgate EM1 or similar the
period for compliance with the
requirements is three months after the
date on which the United States
affecting respect of Step a and four
months in respect of Step B now that
appeals proceeding on the ground set out
to section 174 2ac and F namely that
planning permissions should be granted
but that it that the matters always
don't constitute a booster planning to
try anyway and finally that the
requirements of notice are excessive
foreign
obviously miss Mr Telford so you're a
planning consultant
um in terms of
witnesses as I say we'll come back to
this question of how what's going to
happen over the next day or so but okay
there's a Witnesses you've told me that
you obviously you'll be giving evidence
and that three others and I'm assuming
that's everybody except Mr Steele who
you say is abroad anyway yes uh yeah I
referred to uh Mr stale uh trying to get
him virtually which I will do certainly
um and I'm again trying today the time
difference isn't an issue it's just a
case of trying to get in virtually
um uh Mr Hadfield is available uh if
they uh inquiry proceeds uh the other
two uh will not give evidence simply
because I don't think their strategy
declarations have actually been
challenged uh and uh they're submitted
to be taken as read
um but again uh if they are required uh
they will give that
um I'll give that evidence again on
Earth uh if we can
right well before we go any further uh
Mr light here can I just check whether
that's whether that's correct that Miss
Harris and Mr Atkinson's evidence is not
challenged that is not correct so the
council's case is that the building
wasn't in an independent dwelling
um for those years both those Witnesses
are arguing that it was uh that evidence
May certainly has been challenged
oh
foreign
I think what they say in their statement
was that there was simply aware of it
being occupied and uh and uh Tyler
Harris is actually the occupant I don't
think she's claiming anything other than
that and stating anything other than
that nor is
um uh the the other
um uh Saturday declaration so I don't
think they're arguing that I think they
do stating the fact that they were aware
of it being occupied uh I don't think
they're involved in the argument as to
whether that occupation was lawful or
otherwise
yes I mean I I obviously don't get too
bogged down in this at the moment
um
obviously Miss Harris can only speak to
her sort of recent experience I think
it may be I should speak for for Mr
lighthead but as far as Mr Atkinson's
concerned I had may want to explore the
extent to the extent to which what Mr
Atkinson says
there's anything in particular I
understand that I don't uh I don't um
argue against that in any way at all I
would just simply trying to interpret
what they were saying in their study
their decorations uh if Mr Atkinson is
required then I'll I'll make that known
now Mr lighthead as far as that's
concerned obviously
um is for you how you want to present
your your case
um you so you're as far as you're
concerned it is necessary for you to
challenge what's being said in those
statutory declarations rather than
simply comment on the white or cogency
of their evidence with respect to us it
it seems to me it's the other way around
it's for the appellant representative
case as it sees fit yes um as with any
uh with witness need any Corp sitting or
any inquiry who produces a statement and
then doesn't make themselves available
for cross-examination uh
uh inevitably an application or a
submission will be made to place uh
little weight on that
um the nature of um Miss Tyler's
assuming this Tyler is living there the
nature of um how she's come to be living
there in the circumstances of whether
it's an independent dwelling or whether
she's living there in some other way
um are are highly uh relevant
um but it is entirely for Mr Telford how
he wishes to present his case all right
so so that's the positions itself that
if you if you choose not to call
materials and miss Mr Atkinson then then
it it is to like have all make
submissions on on the um what I can send
from their evidence I understand that
yes thank you
and have you made it are you able to
make a decision on that now whether you
whether you will wish I can't I would
need to speak to uh someone first before
I do that okay
foreign
thank you very much
and for the council we have Mr Mr
lighthead and understand you have to
have just two witnesses Sharon Edwards
enforcement officer and Julian horley
principal planning enforcement officer
is that correct that's that's correct
sir thank you thank you
foreign
are there any others at this stage who
know that they want to will want to
speak I won't hold you to it one way or
the other in other words if you change
your mind because I don't want to speak
I won't make you and if you don't tell
me at this point we can change your mind
and say later that you'd like to speak
um my name is can you hear me all right
yes I can yes hi there my name is uh
planning um Brian yes um but it's not
terribly clear
[Music]
um
but I can hear you
bryony Barrett
oh yes
planning uh we submitted to
representations as part of the appeal on
behalf of Mrs Sally Shaw and her family
who are neighbors of the site
um we we're mainly hearing just an
observation of capacity but I guess I
wouldn't prefer to reserve the right
opportunity to speak if I'd be necessary
absolutely thank you so you'll see
they've put in um risen submissions yes
um
and you've seen those Mr Telford yes I
have to say yes thank you
thank you very much now I have a copy of
the council's notification letter
regarding the date and venue for the
inquiry and the list of persons notified
and there were two
uh letters in response to the original
notification of the appeals namely from
IBA planning on behalf of Mr marples Mrs
marples Mr short and Mrs Marshalls sure
all the new Road Mill thought that was
the 18th of February 2022 and a letter
from Martin peace a wooden view Milford
Lane holmesfield that was undated but
received on the 1st of February 22. I
take it everybody has copies of those
yes sir good and I'm not I'm not aware
of any other representations
right
I did send out a uh pre-inquiry note
which obviously the main parties have
got as well as as IBA planning and in
that note I set out the list of plans
that I have on file so obviously I've
got the
notice that the plans attached to the
enforcement notices
and then in relation to a bill appeal B
I have plans
showing the what's referred to as the
outbuilding and the garage
um is that the list that I included in
the pre-inquiry notes complete and
accurate
yes sir yeah
yeah
thank you
now
um
as far as those plans are concerned I
just might just clarify a couple of
points
um first for a few Mr lighthead the the
outbuilding shown colored green on the
enforcement notice and respect of the
appeal B is unfinished but is the
council happy that what has been built
so far Accords with the plans that I've
just referred to particularly in
relation to the footprint Eve's height
and ridge height
so I I know this is inquiry but it might
be easier if it's poorly uh speaks you
directly on that yes
um yeah it appears to be correct
although we've not actually gone out and
verified the information on the plans
exactly
so we've not taken physical measurements
of the heights of the building yeah
but in terms of their appearance they
appear to be correct
and Mr Telford as far as that's
concerned
um I'm assuming you you say those plans
are accurate but the the issue is is not
that the buildings don't
when measured
literally from from the ground adjacent
to the walls don't exceed the tolerances
in the Deep video but you say that they
should be measured from elsewhere so
they're entirely accurate they do exceed
not on the face of things exceed the the
limits in the Deep video
um yes that uh my argument has been that
the ground level uh uh is a different
point from which the height should be
measured as far as the buildings are
concerned uh and they were manufactured
to those plans off-site uh and as far as
I know and as far as my client knows uh
they're being built in accordance with
what he ordered uh and the design that
he got
I'm just trying to make it's just trying
to bottom out whether I'm going to need
to be faffing around with measurements
uh we haven't disputed and we don't
dispute the councils uh measurements
that they're putting forward as part of
the case certainly no I but I think I
saw some measurements that were slightly
different from the ones that are shown
on the plan that's why I'm that's why
I'm asking but um
whatever the measurements are they're
greater than than what's specified in
the gpdu
um yes the the measurements are above uh
irrespective of the ground level
argument uh that they are above the uh
tolerant Associates yeah
foreign
that's been constructed in accordance
with the plans
and again the same replies we've not
actually been able to check and taken
physical measurements of it but it
appears to be correct
an appearance
is this the former garage sir this is a
no you know the new the new girl the new
garage sorry yes okay it's the same
situation yeah
thank you
now I did I mentioned a couple of things
in the planning sorry the pre-inquiry
note that I hadn't got but I've noticed
what um one two others one was the um
there's the planning contravention
notice which is called document three
but I haven't got the plan that was
associated with that
um
planning contravention notice so if that
could be
emailed to the employment federal case
officer the team E2
um
email address that would be helpful
and
um similarly but in the pre-inquirer
owner I also asked for a copy of the
plan attached to Colin Steele's statute
declaration I've only got the text I
haven't got the plan
so that could be emailed as well
TV2 last week was it oh well yeah I'll
have to double check that I haven't um I
haven't essentially it's the same plan
that was submitted with the LDC
application yes there was no separate
plan submitted with the sign declaration
um design Declaration on both the LDC
and the enforcement notice are the same
and they both refer to the LDC Redline
plan
sorry so um the plan attached to the
planning controvention notice is the
same as the ODC plan I'm sorry they're
two separate matches so our all with the
planning contravention notice plan to
you now right
but the um the common Steels plan is the
same as the um LDC plan correct
thank you
right okay so yes I have I have got that
thank you
just turning to proofs of evidence now
as far as the opponent's concerned I
don't have formal proofs to such but I
do have Mr telford's
a statement for appeal Aid and uh with
appendix a Mr telford's supplementary
statement for appeal a which also has an
appendix that's the the law for
development certificate delegation
report
which is also called document 8.
still stash declaration the first of
July 2022
Robert hadfield's Declaration of 16th
February 2020. I've got those dates
right that doesn't
it does say 2020 it is 2022 sir but uh
um it was written on by hand
um
when it was being signed but uh I've
just noticed that myself but he
certainly wasn't just done this year it
wouldn't have been done in 2020 because
it wasn't required at that time yeah
well I I hadn't noticed that before so
so Mr hadfield's only saying that should
be 2022. I can't say yes and uh
um yes
uh
thank you
I mean I usually for a month or two
still after January still right the
previous year but I don't need to keep
it going for a year
I think I could use that as an argument
and then Tyler Harris's Declaration of
the 16th of February 2022
and the
I'll call it a statement of Richard
Atkinson of the 16th of February 2022 as
I say that doesn't really
it doesn't really meet the tests of a
statutory declaration as such I
understand that yeah
and then I have your statements to
Telford uh grounds and facts to appeal B
including the enforcement delegation
reports and plans for the garage and out
building
and then for the council I have a proof
from Mr Hawley and there are 11 core
documents and I also have a summary from
Mr Hawley and then a second group from
John Edwards no summary but it's short
proof in any event
I take it all the parties have copies of
those
yes sir
good thank you
so I've read all of those
and I'm happy for them to be taken
largely as read but I'll come back to
that before each witness gives evidence
and opposite up to you how you want to
present your Revenue
and of course in any event
cross-examination can take place in
respect of the full content of proofs I
was going to say I haven't received a
statement of common ground but I did see
an email yesterday talking about a
statement of common ground is there like
is one likely to materialize soon I did
send it back to Julian yesterday sir
um and uh I'd agreed with it apart from
one item which was really not a dispute
but it was just an additional paragraph
I suggested being included
so will that be submitted it will be yes
sir I'll be that soon as possible thank
you chance to incorporate Mr telford's
comments here actually
as soon as I'm able to I'll forward it
thank you
now
um as is usual where we have a ground D
appeal uh claiming that um matters are
immune reinforcement action evidence
um is taken on oath
and as in a course of law uh where
evidence is given I know for failure to
sell the truth can result in prosecution
for perjury and a penalty of up to two
years imprisonment the I believe hard
labor has been abolished
um if my decision is based on false
evidence that may also render the
decision unsafe so it has other
practical consequences
but um are all Witnesses content to
affirm
um that's really the only practical way
of doing it when we have a virtual
inquiry but it has exactly the same
effect in law as evidence given uh once
or not really book
yes sir thank you so I note that um
um several witnesses weren't here to say
that
um
May I um suggest that as each witness
gives evidence yes you you draw it to
their attention yes
um
they were prepared to swear stature
declarations but yes you're quite please
remind me
in the Heat of the Moment I'm not proud
I I'm not I don't mind being reminded of
things that I've forgotten thank you
um now
um
and one thing I should say on on that
score Mr Telford
um just in case it looks like you're
being treated differently where I have a
a witness who is also the advocate I
tend to ask them to take the oath before
they make their opening submissions
because it's not always easy to draw a
line between there's an opening
submission what is actual yeah evidence
obviously I wouldn't do that with Mr
lighthead but that's that's the reason
for that
now um perhaps this is the point at
which to
talk about the um what's going to happen
in terms of whether we do proceed
because there's one point if if I may um
raise it before I apologies Mr Telford
he hasn't been made aware of this and it
may just affect uh what's the size of
the running water
um it seems to me
that cross-examinations clearly needed
on the ground D appeal
as you'll be aware so there is now more
flexibility on appeals as to what can be
heard by a round table there's some
quite technical evidence for instance on
cartilage
um and and on height measurements and
and uh the councils of the view uh that
that could be dealt with
um by by a round table discussion would
greatly speed things up and to be more
targeted uh rather than laboriously
going through everything in in in Cross
examination now Mr Telford may have a
different View and I've not run this uh
by him yet
um and of course you and me have a
stronger as well before I ask Mr
Telephone this deal on that make perhaps
I can say something because I I saw an
email from the council uh late yesterday
it arrived slightly early and I've seen
it my connection has dropped out so I
wasn't aware that they're right it
arrived until quite nice to do so just
as I was clocking off effectively I saw
an email saying can we deal with appeal
B by a round table and I kind of
hurriedly did a response saying no
but that but that was largely because I
mean
um how round table sessions effectively
a hearing but it means preparing
different way obviously I have to direct
the thing and not make sure I've got my
questions worked out and so on I haven't
done that and I wasn't going to be able
to do that last night but it hurts me um
thinking about it
probably at three o'clock in the morning
when I was working by Thunder
which could have been the voice of God
for all I know but anyway
um
it occurred to me that we may be able to
go one stage further I want to explore
that with you and that is that as Mr
telf had made clear in his first request
for a postponement
is the appeal was submitted on the basis
that it will be dealt with through
written representations it is only
appeal a and the ground D on appeal a
which has led to an oral event and it is
only the need for evidence to be given
on oath which has led to that being an
inquiry rather than the hearing but um I
wondered whether
um
the parties would be happy for me to
actually determine ground B sorry appeal
B on the basis of written
representations
um subject to the ability to make
submissions on that those those
representations at the end of the
inquiry not with extra evidence but
commenting on the event the written
evidence that I've already got if that
is the case then that greatly speeds
Roundtable sessions don't always speed
things up as much as you might hope
um uh everybody assumes that they will
but it doesn't always work out like that
um so that was just a thought
um and I'm open to I haven't obviously
made up my mind so so
um check I understand this watch you're
suggesting is that we have the the pla
the ground D yeah on across
cross-examination yes third parties can
and say whatever they want to say yes
and then appeal B will
um proceed by
um
written reps but with oral closing
submissions
that was that was what I was thinking I
mean um yeah as I said I don't know how
how happy you would be with that but if
if it hadn't been if we didn't have a
pla I would be just dealing with this on
the basis of written reps there are
often questions in any written reps
cases I often think I'd quite like to
ask this but we just get have to get by
on the basis of the written
representations if you're content
yourself with written representation
you've made and similarly to the council
then I don't see any particular reason
why I can't proceed on that basis but I
think it would be unrealistic to say
that you can't make any comment about
that in closing submissions so I I think
before the decisions made on that I I
think just having five minutes to be
able to take instructions on that away
from the camera which would be
appreciated
that's fine so um yeah yeah so can I
just comment on that that might help
those discussions we started off uh with
both the parents there were two separate
appeals yeah I don't know whilst they're
being referred to as obviously one uh
there were two subject appeals both
representations uh certainly one appeal
could be separated out again uh and
dealt with my written representations uh
and from our point of view we were
happier with that in the first place as
were the council because we both
submitted our evidence uh uh for that it
was only when the council raised the
issue of Colin Steele's study their
declaration that they inspector at uh
you know decided in fact it should all
be that it's an inquiry so we'd have no
objection to it being done in that way
[Music]
right there may be an issue with the
regulations I I have to say I've not
been in a position before where appeals
have been
separated out again and once the
decision is made to
join whether any man may cause the
Thunder
I'm not suggest I mean I think Mr
Telford there went sort of one stage
further in terms of separating that I'm
not talking about formally separating
them out but
um
whilst this is still an inquiry
if any if I turned up to an inquiry and
both parties said to me actually there's
nothing else I want to say I'm happy to
to rely on my written representations
and the other the other side said the
same thing well
I don't see why I I couldn't proceed on
that basis unless I really needed to ask
lots more questions so I'm not
suggesting that the appeals are
separated out I'm suggesting that
there's still the inquiry relates to
broker deals but if if you're happy to
rely on written reps then I I could
determine it on that basis I don't think
there's anything in the in the
regulations to prevent that and we are
encouraged to to be creative nowadays in
terms of how we deal with with appeals
and consider whether some elements can
be dealt with
um either through Roundtable sessions or
by written reps but Mr Lighthouse as I
said earlier
um I'm not adverse to being it's been
put right if I'm wrong about that please
say so it would take me a little time to
check I have to say so it's an unusual
situation it's not one I've encountered
before
um
well I've got West or open it's a bit
like put it this way if if
um I
if Mr
um Telford
call the witness and just said
I mean there may be yeah call the
witness and just said um you know we
have your proof do you confirm that it's
true
no further questions and you said I have
no cross-examination
then that's effectively where we'd be
I'd be relying on on the written
representations albeit backed up by
confirmation on oath that it's true yeah
you that that is um
that's that's correct that is true I I
need to think about my own professional
responsibility whether I I would have
thought a short discussion yes on each
ground it might be it might be
preferable to having straight written
reps
yeah
um
Round Table session on on a couple of
points I mean there are um
I have put it this way the reason one of
the reasons why I said no straight away
yesterday was because I haven't thought
about what those short couple of points
would be
I mean we yeah it could be um
indeed I mean the independent it seems
to be some difficulty they've you know
if you look at the ground a appeal
they've not suggested it's not
inappropriate development they've not
suggested there's any
um very special circumstances I mean
really it's game over
um
well obviously there's Matt that you
know again that that in itself is a map
um I I don't know so I'm not certainly
not aware that there's a particular
dispute about whether it's inappropriate
this is why I asked Mr Telephone about
whether we prepare for that and the
indication I got was that the
understanding that I formed was that
he'd be happy with representations so
can I just can I just throw something
else in because it's something else in
if it had been written in
representations uh the appellant would
have had the chance to make comments uh
on the council's uh submission
um in an inquiry the appellants
opportunity to comment on the council's
submission would have been uh that
opportunity would have been taken then
yeah uh on the written representations
the appellant hasn't had the opportunity
to to comment on the council's
submission
yeah okay well that's
um
I I talked about the opportunity to
comment in terms of closing submissions
but that's not necessarily the same
thing because so that that wouldn't
involve additional evidence as such in
terms in terms of commentary so that
that is a problem that's why I asked you
Mr Telfer whether you are happy with
that
um so that made that may be the
particular fly in the equipment really
um but uh and but just so you know where
where I stand on on a point that Mr Mr
lighthead just just made
um
the and when I I often
think it's useful for me to say what I'm
thinking at any particular point in time
just so that you've got an opportunity
to address that I I'm I'd like to make
it clear that when I say these things I
haven't necessarily made up my mind I've
closed my mind to to other arguments but
I think it's useful to know what points
you've got to address and as far as very
special circumstances are concerned
there's been no that that's not been
articulated but there's been reference
to
what I might call a fallback position
and there's been referenced to the
materials that have been used in the
construction of the building and so on
I'm not making any comment about whether
that has the very physical circumstances
but those are the sorts of things that
um
that I would have to take account of
um now Mr lighthead in view of what's
just been said by myself and about the
opportunity to to comment
uh does that then you just bring you
back to your Round Table suggestion or
is there anything further you want to
think about in terms of
whether
I'm just checking the uh Italian country
planning course procedure England rules
which seems to be
the right place to yeah to look
um we expected rule 12 a fifth rule 1512
inspection may take into account any
written representational evidence or any
other dot could received by it from any
person before an inquiry offers or
during the Quarry provided that he
discloses it at the inquiry I mean
that's not designed as a submission from
the parties
um you you can um
refuse to commit to the giving or
production of evidence or
cross-examination of giving evidence or
presentation of any other matter
which you said considered to be
irrelevant of repetitious
but where you refuse to admit the giving
the Royal and the person wishing to give
the evidence May submit to many evidence
or other maths in writing before the
close of the inquiry so
um I I think the long and the short bit
is that as it is an inquiry if someone
wants to say something unless you've got
a good reason to stop them saying
if they don't want to say anything
um that's that's that's another matter I
think
yeah I would have thought both parties
would want to say things but but I need
to take instructions all right okay well
I will I will adjourn
um and unless you use that I think you
said five minutes shall I make it 10 10
minutes okay thank you sir thank you sir
that I will leave leave the meeting and
rejoin so I'll adjourn until that's
point until five to five to eleven
thank you very much
thank you
so Mr lighthead where have we got to
thank you thank you sir it would take me
a little time to go through regulations
and so on as as to the various options
um
uh we don't think um uh written reps is
a privilege and and it's not clear to me
that that's possible now to do that
under the regulations
um but but I need some some time to
research that
um as to the other options
um the council's preference would be to
have a just a sort of Round Table
discussion we what I didn't realize
yesterday what we didn't realize is
there was the difference in that would
pose to you in in preparing to chair
that
um the other two options is to have a
normal cross-examination like a normal
inquiry
that seems to me on this particular
evidence a lot of details of stuff on
cartridge and Maps particularly over
Zoom it is just going to be
unnecessarily laborious
what we could do
um
in my submission is to have a normal if
we can't have a round table discussion
to have a normal inquiry
where the evidence is basically take
taken as read
but examination in Chief is restricted
to just a few key points that the
witness wants to get across and
cross-examination is again restricted to
just
a
small number of points with most of the
evidence being taken under it I I think
that seems to me that that would be fair
to both parties
I I agree the difficulty is is knowing
in advance what those
um those limited matters are going going
to be well that would be a matter for
the advocates in the same way that any
process examination or any evidence
achievement is always a
uh that's that's that's never agreed in
advance and this inspection is what I
wanted to cover a particular point I
have to say I've never had an inspector
say I mean they expect to set out the
main issues that it'd be for the parties
to work uh within that as as to closing
submissions I because it's a potentially
a one-day inquiry I I've made a start on
wishing uh closing some submissions it
doesn't much matter to the council
whether I end up doing bits of that
orally or um bits to the fact um in uh
in writing
um but um
but obviously if you ask me crazy
questions sometime will be needed to
prepare this whether they're on tomorrow
morning or you know how that works I
will really believe to you but um
I wanted to
what can I just so that I know what
we're dealing with can I can just ask is
everybody available tomorrow I am
available tomorrow
yes sir yes yes I am also
good that helps
um
so
so it that that being the case
um
it's possible that we could effectively
deal with
um
it's possible that we could effectively
deal with appeal a during the course of
today I hope that depends on the Mr
telephone's Witnesses available that's
another variable in this and he said he
needs to check who would be available
um which would give me the opportunity
um this evening to
prepare for a round table session I mean
mark from a purely personal point of
view my preference would be for
um effectively evidence uh
as far as evidence Chiefs concerned for
proofs to be taken as read and then
simply
um any so so Mr Telford has said has
indicated they've got no had no
opportunity to comment on council's
evidence so his evidence and she could
be just limited to what he needs to
comment on in the council's evidence
and if you were able to limit your
cross-examines those across examination
to essential points then that's great
but I just don't know I can't tell how
that's going to go I don't know what you
think is essential I don't know what to
tell if it thinks is essential
I could I could
um
uh prepare for a round type of session
tomorrow
um I'm also participating slightly
because to some extent it depends what's
in the statement of common ground which
I haven't yet steam I so there are
clearly I have some things in mind that
I would want to focus on but I haven't
thought about
exactly the issues that I want to cover
around table session
so is it is it
convenient at this stage to say what I
wanted to say about an adjournment
the adjournment may give you the
opportunity to look at that yes well I
just I just wanted to talk through these
various options because that might
affect what you wanted to say about
about understand that yeah okay all
right thank you
yes so what do you want me to say sorry
I
uh Sarah I previously set out the
reasons why I asked initially for a
postponement and I understood that but
you wanted to open and get uh matters
like this uh sorted out first uh so
obviously I'm making an application to a
journey inquiry uh so that um I wouldn't
take it further then uh the emails
outlined why I've not been able to
layers with the appellant or his lawyers
in complete and necessary paperwork
regarding the appeal that's why this
statement a common ground was late
um in 51 years and local government did
Private Practice I've never come across
such circumstances that have caused the
issues with this appeal and I hope that
I'm or anyone at present ever comes
across such circumstances again as a
result I've not had the opportunity to
discuss all the purpose sufficiently
with the appellant and fully examine and
be instructed on all the issues raised
by the council and the interested
parties
the appellant and his Witnesses are
unprepared as a result of not being
fully informed to take part in these
proceedings
the German will allow full witness
statements to be prepared and a bundle
submitted not raising new evidence but
responding to the council's statement of
case and supporting documents
matters raised therein required detail
examination clarification and following
that detailed consideration it may be
possible to speed up the inquiry
one matter that is additional
information is a matter for my client
that came to light on Friday last uh and
I've drawn the council's attention to it
was that he received a council tax
demand for Greenwood Lodge as a dwelling
house
that demand no doubt as a result of the
discussions between the enforcement
officer and the council tax department
seeks back payments for council tax
periods between the 1st of January 2012.
and the 23rd of August 2022 in the sum
of 17
429 pounds and six pence
in speaking in a German solely a result
of their difficulties I've outlined the
appellant doesn't seek to gain any
Financial or other benefit from a delay
uh fully appreciate the adjournment will
cause inconvenience and possibly
additional costs being incurred so I
don't make this request lightly however
in the interest of fairness the
Appellate should have the opportunity to
make his case consider all matters and
the advice is offered as well as dealing
with any issues that may be raised in
cross-examination
sir I refer to her on issue of fairness
and you'll know this better than I do
I'm sure but
um law Justice nuji in a case of builta
uh against traditional Finance services
um in fact it was a an Inquirer a cut of
a pale inquiry dressed by
um number five Chambers uh he says
fairness involves fairness to both
parties but inconvenience to the other
party is not a relevant countervailing
factor and is usually not a reason for
refusing an adjournment
about the concerns of the council uh in
the email from Mr Purcell about the
timing of this request but I must doubt
I was in no position to make the request
any earlier than I did and whilst he
believed that nothing had changed for me
for some time to avoid the request being
made earlier I can assure him that my
circumstances unfortunately changed
radically during the last 18 weeks
I don't seek an indefinite adjournment
and my client wishes to ring the
disturbance in his property to an end
having taken advice I will be available
to resume the inquiry face to face and I
advise my client fully on the council's
case in response to his appeals within
three weeks
in the meantime having alerted the
council's wish to cross-examine Mr
Steele on his statutory declaration I
will endeavor to have him truly sorry
virtually available from Thailand for
the resumed inquiry
and I make this request accordingly
so if Mr Thomas finished may I respond
to that page yes so the first point to
making this topic may not be aware of
this but it's Republican quite the
council's aware of the reasons for the
Germans
um it is a public inquiry there are
others in this room and perhaps I was
watching online who who aren't aware and
um
I wonder whether this type of things is
appropriate first of all that those
reasons are
made public or or if you prefer to keep
them private
so I think you're the one that said that
you wanted to keep them confident well I
I I it's it's a matter for you really
but I was anxious that we didn't um uh
personal sense of sensitive personal
information but with with you without
you being happy with it I mean like it's
it could be sort of summarized on the
basis that you have very you know
serious health issues within your family
that you've had had to deal with which
has prevented you from uh keeping it
from from working eventually that's your
that's your case if you want to add more
detail to that then that's that's fine
that's a matter for that's a matter for
you but I just I didn't want uh things
to just come out in the open without
your being content with that no
certainly uh I've worked I think in the
last 18 weeks I've worked on a very
limited basis
um uh the situation is that I've not
been able to leave uh my wife on her own
um uh for health reasons and also for
psychological reasons related to that
and that is what has really delayed me
uh in being able to discuss the matters
in full with my clients uh hopefully
that uh
[Music]
serious treatment is coming to an end uh
radiotherapy is the next course
um but that isn't doesn't have the
effects that chemotherapy has had
so uh it has not been possible for me to
advise my clients fully it's no no
problem uh for caused by my clients
seeking to delay or disrupt matters it's
purely the fact that they've not been
able to be advised fully
thank you uh Mrs topper that's the uh
the the first point and the council has
uh said in its uh written communication
with with the inspector and and with you
how sorry we are
um and that we wish your wife and and
indeed you well
um the the difficulty with this uh
appeal um and you're already aware of
cost application may follow but these
issues are not new issues they've been
known to you uh for some time
um if uh numerous deadlines
have been missed and then with less than
a week before the inquiry at that point
uh you you've asked to adjourn but the
council is ready and willing to go now
and there's no reason from the council's
point of view why the inquiry cannot
proceed
today uh that's the first point the
second point is this uh which is that
um
the appellant didn't provide any proofs
or any other evidence
uh by the deadline in email last week uh
you said to the inspector that no
further Evidence would be produced uh
now you're saying
um well further evidence will be
produced but it won't be new evidence it
would just be new evidence on things
that aren't new
um
it it seems to me that
um that is going to take
additional time and additional expensive
accounts will need to consider that
evidence and consider whether it now
needs to put in rebuttal evidence
of its own
um if you want to put in new evidence it
will only be fair for the council to
have the opportunity to respond to that
in uh the normal way as team council tax
uh payments I I I I can speak to Council
on a limited extent for that it's not
part of this inquiry it's not relevant
to the inquiry
um and are not instructed on that my
understanding of the situation is that
your client has effectively told the
council
uh that is liable for council tax since
2012. if it's an independent wedding is
liable for calf attacks so he's
effectively written to the council and
said it's an independent dwelling we've
been liable for council tax since 2012
please build us now that doesn't need to
say that the council has made a a
judgment in fact the council doesn't
accept it is an independent dwelling but
if someone phones the council and says
effectively look at me I'm liable for
council tax
um they can't really be surprised if
they get a whopping counter tax bill
so just on that I I raised council tax
simply because the council said that no
evidence had been given to support the
uh uh studied sorry they claim uh that
it's a a dwelling
um because no council tax records have
been produced uh we didn't instigate
this uh my client did not ring the
council and say I'm liable for council
tax since 2012. uh that in fact came
when he asked somebody from the council
uh to command in fact he didn't ask from
the council he asked the valuation
office uh to come and uh put a value or
a banding on uh his property or the
launch so it wasn't as a request from my
client to the council tax revenues
Department the only contact he had with
nothing specific no size of property no
um dates they asked them to come a good
evaluation on that property for council
tax purposes but that's as far as it
went as far as the council and the
council tax department are concerned
I've seen correspondence and I think
it's been circulated uh from uh Julian
Hall later the uh council tax department
asking questions regarding the property
so if I may if we forgive you I'm sure
you don't want some constant back back
and forth but just two points I think my
little friend's confusing the two issues
the issue when the council in this
inquiry raised the issue of accounts of
tax payments that that was simply to
evidence whether or not the dwelling is
an independent dwelling house if if a
dwelling is an independent wedding house
you'd expect things like bank statements
council tax separate bin collections
being on the Electoral role a separate
posted address all that would be
evidence of an independent uh dwelling
house so the reference to council tax
payments was simply a an issue to help
the appendant to evidences kcp paying
counter tax since 2012. uh that the
council probably at that point would say
okay we accept as an independent
dwelling
um
the the issue over whether council tax
is now due
um is an entirely separate matter from
the proceedings
beforehand uh you're not being asked and
it wouldn't be proper in my solution so
for you to make a finding offer now of
course if the appendant loses its
grounded appeal uh he can go back to the
council and say look I'm not liable for
council tax
um that's that's that's going to be a
very strong submission for that if he
wins his grandee appeal uh then um the
council May well pursue him for council
tax it sounds like they are but the
appeal procedure for that is totally
separate from these proceedings
so I I only raised that because it was
additional information uh because in the
comment I made before and that no new
information will be put forward uh my
client is aware that if he fails on
ground D that he will in fact uh respond
back to the council tax department I
only raise it uh as a matter that has
arisen uh and I know the enforcement
department were involved with a council
tax department uh over uh Colin Steele's
occupation of the property but I don't
want I raise that purely as an aside I
didn't want it to Cloud the issue or the
request for an adjournment
all right I mean as far as council tax
is concerned
um it's something that's nearly always
referred to proceedings of this nature
but the fact that somebody doesn't want
to pay council tax or hasn't paid
council tax doesn't prove they weren't
there but similarly the fact that the
council requests the payment of council
doesn't prove that they were the council
tax department aren't responsible for
resolving that issue in the playing
context so it's a very limited
significance put it that way
um in this in these appeals
um Mr Mike had referred to your
indication that you would want to put in
you said not new evidence but additional
evidence if it's not new what's what
purpose does it serve if it's adding to
anything the council may wish to comment
on uh uh they wouldn't have had the
opportunity if it had been a written
appeal uh our uh the balance comments on
the council statement her final
um but at so if we comment on the
council's case which my client wishes to
do uh then he would in fact uh you know
at an inquiry would have um or if you
commented on it at the hearing uh the
council would have had a chance to to
respond
um if it's a written appeal they would
still reserve the right to comment on
the council statement
now you said you said you'd be available
from three weeks but you've also said
that you'd be putting in you'd want to
put in additional witness things as you
put in
um obviously as Mr lighthead indicated
if that happened the council needs time
to actually consider that
um it wouldn't necessarily be the case
that they would have to put in rebuttal
evidence because they can they can
rebutt it during the course of the
inquiry might possibly make the inquiry
long by doing it that way but what I'm
saying is three weeks there's a lot to
happen within the it's not going this
isn't going to be resumed within three
weeks if there's going to be further
Evidence so the the point about three
weeks was my availability not that it
could be done in three weeks it was just
I think in your email and I think the
council had indicated I think it was Mr
Purcell said I hadn't given a time as to
when I would be available
um all I'm saying is from three weeks
onwards I will be available
miss Mr lighthead as as far as further
Evidence is concerned if if the opponent
isn't allowed to put in any further
written written evidence that won't
prevent them
commenting orally at the inquiry on
what's been said in your uh in your
proofs so often we're faced with this
this difficult event which is the best
which is the most efficient way of
dealing with this is it better to have
some further written evidence and I hope
that that will shorten the teams in the
inquiry or just deal with it on the hoof
at the inquiry well so that's um uh if
it's dealt with that's an inquiry the
inquiry can take place uh
near a time that that's you know there's
Justice argument for that but of course
it may extend inquiry
um I I don't think the council have
objection to further written evidence
but as with any inquiry
um
um it would I mean presumably in the
form of a proof
um with with perhaps statutory
declarations attached but as with any
inquiry
uh the council would
um need to consider whether to admit a
rebuttal group now
um the usual situation and my advice to
clients generally is is you know unless
you really need to do it don't do it
it's just going to annoy the inspector
that's a um so it doesn't mean to say
that um rebuffal evidence will
necessarily following but if it's
considered necessary uh then then then
yes um the council would want to submit
rebuttal loans yes all right
now
um
although what we haven't obviously what
we haven't bottomed out anyways is
actual timings having listened to
um what's been said
although I accept
that um
whilst Mr telford's circumstances have
been extremely difficult
over the last 18 weeks plus
he could have requested a postponement
at an earlier stage I'd set that is the
case
nevertheless
uh
it's not something over which the
appellant
had control
and I also accept that as a result of
these circumstances
the appellant hasn't had the proper
opportunity to consider all the evidence
and to take advice on it
and whilst it does lead to inconvenience
for everybody concerned and to the
council it causes delay to the
proceedings
to proceed
now
I believe would result in Injustice to
be appellant because they wouldn't have
had a proper opportunity to put their
case effectively
and although it's something that I have
been very anxious to avoid I think for
those reasons and a German is
the uh the the right way to to proceed
in the interests of fairness
Mr Telford has been
um has made it clear that he's aware of
what the consequences might be in terms
of costs and I don't need to say any
more about that at this stage
but I think
um
not not only for the reasons I've just
given but also because
there is considerable uncertainty about
how how this inquiry is to proceed what
evidence is going to be given and in
what format in what form whether it's
Round Table session or whether it's
formal cross-examination and so on
that it's actually quite difficult at
this point to predict how long the
inquiry will take if we proceed now and
therefore it may be that it would have
to be adjourned in any event
and with all those things taking all
those things into consideration I think
it would be better
to have a longer adjournment and to put
in place mechanisms which at least give
us the Fighting Chance to proceed on a
more efficient basis than we resume
and I will come back to that but we can
talk in terms of deadlines for
submission of any further written
evidence a deadline for
rebuttals from the council if so advised
before we actually resume
domain So within that process being the
opportunity for a a more focused
statement of common ground and narrow
issues further further still
that does leave us with the
the difficult question about when we are
going to resume I don't know whether
parties have actually
considered availability and obviously
there's my own availability to
Mr Salford you've indicated that
obviously you it's not just you as
witnesses to to
um to bring it to take into
consideration as well have Beyond this
three weeks that you have
indicated do you have other dates that
you know you need to avoid after that
three-week period
uh at this stage you know because
obviously the circumstances I've not
been able to book anything or plan
anything uh too far ahead in the future
so uh Beyond three weeks I will make
myself available for uh whatever
occasion
and do you have any information about
witness availability
uh I understand uh that Beyond uh the
theory that I'm available other
witnesses will make themselves available
at all times
um certainly not far ahead uh Colin
Steele will be available it may be
virtually
um but um uh it will be available
uh timings uh obviously it'll be about
just about ready to bed but
um I think about eight hours ahead I'm
not quite sure but um uh certainly it
will be available anyway
foreign
within all this Mr lighthead is the the
other issue about whether
um The Inquirer resumes virtually or
face to face Mr telford's expressed I
mean it could be a blended at the event
obviously Mr Thailand Mr Thailand Mr
Steele is unlikely uh to to attend from
Thailand so it's it's possible for some
witnesses to to give evidence
um virtually and others to be face to
face is your preference Mr Telford still
for a face-to-face event it always is so
yes
but having caused the problems uh
obviously I'm I mean everybody else's
hand in that respect
Mr lighthead do you have any views on
that
uh so I think um in general terms the
face-to-face event is it is always
better we learned in a pandemic about
the virtual uh inquiry is possible and
works well uh so I'm taking instructions
don't look at Mr audio sort of Blended
event which would be appropriate if this
is nodding
yes I mean
um I have to be careful I don't know
um speak out of turn in terms of what
the planning inspector's overall
position is but the bottom the bottom
line is it's for the inspector to decide
which is the most appropriate but I have
dealt I have done virgin events where
evidence is given on oath and it's not
always been
satisfactory sometimes it's worked very
well other times it's created all sorts
of
difficulties
so my preference is for a face-to-face
event
but there is no reason why some
weaknesses can't give evidence
um virtually if you like so just just on
the face to face if you decide that
dealing with notice number two is we'll
refer to it uh which is the building
we'll see if you felt it that was better
dealt with around the table
um then obviously face to face will be
ideal and far better in that respect
um uh and uh sometimes uh I think
uh been involved in many informal
hearings inspectors sometimes prefer to
adjourn uh they
um the proceedings uh to to the site
itself uh which may be helpful to you it
may not be
well
um winning yeah something that's
interesting we start putting all these
different procedures together but uh
although it would be around play the
session it'd still be an inquiry and
there was I wouldn't normally have a
wouldn't a journey inquiry I understand
through the site
um I have done that once so with mugs of
tea with crazy exhibitions around the
Helen's kitchen table
yeah
all right
um
that that the other the other thing
about all this Mr lighthead is that
um certainly if there's a longer a
German then I I see no reason in
principle by a round table session
should not be appropriate for a
thoughtful for appeal for appeal B so
there is that advantage
um
if after considering it so you take the
view I mean it's because of the change
in the uh rules a couple years ago there
is this flexibility now I mean for
instance a five-year housing land Supply
you might have cross-examination on the
policy basis but not on the disputed
sides so even within a topic there can
still be yeah
flexibility so as you consider the
matter uh and the evidence whatever
comes in
um you feel that across the damage will
assist you on a particular matter uh it
just seemed to be yesterday looking
through this detailed cartilage evidence
that that cross-examining for three
hours on different plans over time uh
perhaps wasn't the most efficient way of
doing it I mean Mr Telford I'm sure
would enjoy that but um but
uh you may feel that a Roundtable
discussion of that sort of evidence
it may maybe I mean it's just
um
obviously
Mr Telford would have
that would have um would give the bulk
of the appends evidence in relation to
the issue of Curtis and so on but it's
not it's not entirely divorced from
factual issues about how has the land
been used and occupied and Mr Telford
may not be the person to give evidence
on that and you may wish to
cross-examine the appellant on on those
particular issues so it's not you know
it's not entirely straightforward it's
not entirely neat is it and you can say
oh well ground B it's an appeal B is
entirely suitable for Round Table so it
is it is tricky but we at least have the
opportunity to actually consider
consider this but I I one thing I would
say Sir is with the um humble advocates
in mind I I think if there is to be
cross-examination they need to know
before the day certainly because they
need to just as you need to prepare
questions soon
well I think
um
I think what what I would do I'm sorry
this is all a bit rambling but we're
just edging our way towards a solution
if you like but I think what I would do
is I would indicate that in principle
I'm happy for the uh the appeal B to be
dealt with by way of a round table
session but of course once you've seen
the evident the further Evidence
you may take a different View
um so it wouldn't have to be fixed in
stone but I think the starting point
would be a round table session four
appeal B so I think that would be my
preference at this stage but I will set
it I will set all this out in in writing
after I uh adjourn but I just want to
make sure we've got these various things
covered and obviously the reason I asked
about face-to-face is because then we're
not just concerned about when Advocates
and Witnesses are available but we're we
need a venue to be available and yes I
and and and there's also the matter of
closing uh for Missions it's always
difficult on a one-day inquiry the old
way of doing it was you just do it
already now inspectors like written
closing submissions it is Unity time to
prepare this yes
um you see what let me again let me tell
you my thinking on that I I don't
generally like
just taking closing submissions in
writing because I nearly always have
something I want to clarify with the
actors and I also think that closing
submissions are actually quite an
important part of the public inquiry
process and so when people have sat
particularly when it's a multi-day
inquiry people have sat through heard
all the evidence and then they get
deprived of the opposition to hear hear
the closing submissions on both on both
sides so my preferences for is
foreclosing submissions not to be in
writing but again the last inquiry I did
everything was face to face except
closing submissions were given virtually
so people had an opportunity to hear
them there was a there was a time
um available for The Advocates to
finalize closing Solutions people I
heard them so there's a number of ways
you can deal with it yeah
um I can I off I will often if it's if
it's a two-day inquiry I will do the
site visit at the beginning of the
second if all that's left is closing
submissions in the site does it do the
site visit and come back and here
closing submission so there's some
opportunity but also having done some
advocacy myself many years ago I I do
appreciate how difficult it is when the
inspector says on a one-day inquiry can
I have closed exhibitions in writings so
for instance yesterday so I spent a
considered amount of time writing
closing submissions uh assuming it was
going to be a one-day win because of the
possibility of a one-day inquiry so I
think if a directory could be made in
advance of the
normally I say closing submissions in
writing if possible yeah and I will I
will then organize them facilitate that
so far as I can if it's not possible
it's not possible I mean you're not you
know and um but and also I I you know I
have some doubt about the value of
closing submissions that are written
before the evidence
it say the ground D I mean without
giving too much you know I've left bits
where I can add in yeah and then another
and there's some legal discussion on
curtinich um I will say to everyone I
refer to another case called highly um
which doesn't add anything new to um
black Black Bush I could send it to this
topic if you wanted it but it does have
a helpful summary of like things of what
you can and what you can't do when
discussing cursive there's a bit of that
and now
does the council have we've got an
indications from Mr
tell that any any time after
um three weeks perhaps excluding
Christmas day I was just about to add
that yes
of their game but do you have because
before I start looking at my availa
availability
um it would be useful to have some idea
about the earliest point at which you
the council might be available
Advocates Witnesses and venue yeah are
we looking for one or two days so
I think it would be safest to say too if
we finish sooner than that great but
it's safest to say too I haven't seen
obviously I've never seen this before
this extra evidence further Evidence
might be
as I said in terms of our route
availability then the next three two
days that we've got is the first and
second of December
and that's in the council chamber if we
intended to meet in person
let me just have a look at my
we have a new system now that um
what we had what was called The Old
Chart system was much was very easy what
we have now is not so easy so bear with
me apologies I've mentioned
it is
I mean whether we can investigate
another venue so there's not at the
council offices we sometimes do that
well it's just that I don't I don't
adjourn without without saying what the
date is going to be if you think if you
think if you think that you would be
able to find another venue then I can I
can adjourn to a specific date to a
venue to be advised but if you're not
confident about that then I'd rather
okay
yeah without actually having a look at
the availability of some of the other
venues it's very difficult to say so if
it would assist as well I am pretty
booked up until the second week of
November
which isn't that
far ahead of the well it's a bit of five
yeah I mean
there I I could find two days before
then for instance the third third week
of October
but Mr Hall is saying the council has
not been you before end of December
anyway so there's a date on Thursday and
Friday which is the third and fourth of
November I can't do that I'm in the
middle of a six day trial I'm throat
the 17th or 18th of November
these are on Thursday and Friday which
were discounted but because
realistically said I mean the reason um
if the appellant needs time to put some
evidence together
um where we now were this fourth and
then no no oh sorry November yes that's
about eight weeks that gives I think
both parties time to the government
you have seven seven years old that
works for you well on the phone let me
just check what's what's happening the
following week because I often say yes
and then I look at what I've got
following week
um
right well but strangely remarkably that
uh hang on oh hang on oh dear
unfortunately I've got
um
a hearing on the 16th but I'm almost
certain it's going to overrun
thank you
so I'm afraid that's too risky for me
it's in the other end of the country as
well
yeah we're then back to the first and
second of December
sorry I thought was that I thought there
was some doubt over the first and second
December
only because it's a Friday
oh I see
foreign
yeah well that looks
at the moment
sorry I'm hesitating as I've got to
decipher the information I get now which
isn't as clear as it could be but
um that looks okay first and second
December
and to get me out of my work Christmas
party you know
that's good or bad
yeah
okay
okay
[Music]
so I'm just I'm just making sure I'm not
storing up great trouble for myself
because of what's either side but I
think that's okay
right
um
okay so that would be the council
chamber
you see in terms of the number of days
so we've affected although we've done
some useful things today in terms of
talk about how things could go we've not
obviously touched on the evidence and
we've got um
six Witnesses so it is that it has to be
two days
I would say
and of course we have the added problem
of fading light in December when it
comes to the site visit so
right
um
oh all right so on that basis
um
in terms of
proofs of evidence from the appellant
commenting on councils
proofs Mr Telford if I if I specified
four weeks
for completion of those that would take
us to the beginning
of October
and then
um let's just talk about dates
um we're now on the
6th of September
so if
foreign
by the 4th of October
rebuttals
from the council if so advised
by
first of November
that puts us back in a position which we
should have been now in with proofs
effectively being available four weeks
prior
do the the inquiry
um and
if I could also ask for a statement of
common ground
by the first of November
to include because I haven't mentioned
this before but to include any suggested
conditions in relation to
the Deep application on it on a PLP
foreign
a statement of Common Ground by the 1st
of November of 2022 as well we include a
schedule of suggested conditions
in relation to the dean deprecation on
appeal B
there is another point so we can get as
much value out of this morning as
possible there is another point that I
would like to touch on though and that
is first of all before I do that are
there any problems with what I've
indicated there no no sir and and just
one other point of the timetable I I
take instructions but I do a interpret
the anticipate this already but I do
anticipate a cost application yes
sometimes will be needed and I assume
you what that's in writing music yes
please
um and certainly that will
um well yes I mean
um
maybe we should factor that in at the
moment because
um
like prompts cost application but at the
moment you know
at this stage the basis of on which you
want to make a cost application so it
would be helpful to have the cost
application because I'm just thinking
about you know the progress of the
inquiry when we do resume because the
application
um
well would there be any yeah the cost
application in writing by
the first of November as well the the
difficulty with that I'm not sure it's a
big difficulty but just thinking off the
top of my head
um the cost which which will be wasted
will be essentially anything from now
going to have been living conferences
which will need to take place to review
the the evidence to consider you know
draft rebuttal priests or that sort of
thing uh competence in preparing for the
next inquiry and and the cross occur
during inquiry itself uh those costs
won't have actually been
and could until
the beginning of inquiry even if it can
be predicted what they're likely to be
now of course the set amount isn't
determined by user for the money but the
principle of the costs for
um conferences and and so on it might be
better on the first day of the inquiry
to receive that in writing
rather than or a week before the
requirement the reason I said the cost
application by the first of November is
because then I could ask for a written
response to that from yeah repellent
that doesn't mean to say that it this
can't be supplemented at that by itself
I'm just trying to minimize the amount
of time at the inquiry on on costs I
think you know that is the principles
that are the difference in terms of
unreasonableness yeah and the the broad
categories of expense that will be
incurred which I think are predictable
it's largely predictable but anything
that isn't predictive well you can say
so on during the inquiry but and of
course that's subject to instructions
that
um Billy is something which um has been
raised before
yeah
so if I was to say
written cost application by first of
November
2022
um written costs
reply because obviously you get I'm not
going to ask for your final final
comment on the cost application in
writing prior to the inquiry but
um a written across response if I was to
say by the 15th
of November
then that gives us a fighting chance to
deal with that relatively quickly
at the inquiry
I thought I don't want the situation
where even two days isn't enough when we
resume another adjournment will be
pretty disastrous yeah
um
right
oh and I again a bit as I indicated
earlier
at this stage
propose
to deal with
appeal B
through a round table session
and whilst it's face to face
happy for
some witnesses if necessary
particularly Mr Steele
to attend virtually
and um
and and this issue of third parties as
as well to go in that when whether you
just wanted to join in with the
Roundtable discussion or whether
um you want them to speak first we're
pretty aligned actually with uh you see
a letter a professional letter from um
I IBA planning I mean when you wish to
hear from them first or whether it's
just going to save time if they just
chip in in the round table
um it is a massive user yeah I mean I I
think it would be better for them to
chip in it in in the round table I I
tend to be prescriptive about it but
it's um it may be that once once they've
heard what you have to say about things
that's not necessarily a great deal to
add
um but I'm again I'm always flexible
about timing when it comes to things
like things like that
and as I said you may come to once
you've seen further Evidence you might
come to a different view about Round
Table a round table session but I I'm
just as I say indicating that matters
principle I think it makes sense given
that that was to be a written
representation as appeared in the first
first instance
now unless there's anything else on
those those sort of matters as I said
there was something else I wanted to
just flag out and that's that's the
point that was raised things to fall is
proof about the fact that the building
the Green Building on
the second note is the subject of appeal
B
is unfinished
no that there is some
um
the case law settled on that that's uh
that uh not everyone realizes but Grande
appeal with the dean planning
application can only be considered for
the state of the building when the
enforcement notice is served that's
where Mr Arnold came into difficulty
um and and I I advise on this endlessly
on the other side of it so I was almost
finished their Barn conversion
um but um that is the position we're in
so independent would need so would be
you need to be satisfied so for the
condition of the buildings uh on on the
date the enforcement notice was uh
served and independent will explain to
you no doubt why an unfinished building
that looks like a dwelling house in the
Greenbelt which is interprevenue
development with no special
circumstances should be given planning
permission
foreign
yes
um
now
but I want to issue arises another issue
rises from it and that's whether whether
there's any need or purpose in
correcting the allegation I mean the the
trouble we have is that an unfinished
building is is still a building in terms
of the definition in the planning Act is
for the structure or erection so of
course the point in our Lord isn't that
um couldn't get planning permission no I
know but yeah but it just can't be
finished no it can't it can't get I
can't Grant plan information for a
finished building and I've just got to
decide whether it would be appropriate
to Grant planning permission for a
finished building sorry an unfinished
built building but I'm just
um just just it's a it's a technical
Point really but whether whether the
allegation should be without planning
permission building operations
comprising where
the partial direction of a building or
um the erection of an uncompleted
building as I say the trouble with that
is a it's still a building you're going
to send it yeah
yeah yeah so Mr Telford um as I said the
the the the the terms of the deemed
application are prescribed by the
the terms of the allegation well the
terms of the allegation is a is a
building but the fact is to notice could
only relate to what was there at the
date that the notice that the notice was
issued and that that the building was
unfinished so
um Dukes accept that point that I can't
Grant even if I'm persuaded
I can't Grant permission for what's
shown on the plans that we've submitted
I can only Grant permission for what was
there when the notice was issued no I
fully understand that yeah yeah
okay
right
is there anything else
that I need to address
I don't think so right thank you so just
just to recap honestly I will
I will set this out in an adjournment
note but I'll adjourn the inquiry until
the first and second of December
to resume in person at the council
chambers
and in the meantime
um the parent to submit proofs of
evidence by
the 4th of October 2022 with rebuttals
from the council if so advised by the
1st of November 2022
together with a statement of Common
Ground including suggested conditions
and together with with application by
the first November and then a written
response from the repellent because the
application supplying 15th of November
2022.
and as I've said
assuming at this place that we will deal
with appeal B through a round table
session and that I'm content for
necessary Witnesses particularly Mr
Steele to attend virtually
all right well thank you very much for
I'm sorry we couldn't make more progress
today but thank you very much for your
your contributions
happy Halloween Happy Guy Fawkes Day
and Advent
all right thank you very much
I can't go before I ask the painting
above your head is there any
relationship between the painter in
yourself well you're supposed to think
that
you know I'm afraid it would be nothing
more than a scribble
it's just a friend of mine saw that at
some shop in London decided they had to
fight for we should rather be a better
this is before I didn't put it up there
for the purposes of virtual inquiries
it's been there for years
thank you I'm not a renaissance man
thank you very much sir yeah thank you
very much thank you